this next one's really going to grind
your gears drew are you ready for this
oh it's got me heated everyone it comes
from buzzfeed so listen a woman in a
bridal party posted texts from her
friend who was the bride the bride wrote
that she'd hand picked all the
bridesmaid dresses and quote they will
all be a size 8 so if you're not a size
8 i recommend hitting the gym
yeah the woman who posted this said
she's a size 12 with no plans of being a
size 8 by december so she's quitting the
bridal party thank you very much
this got me going you know we're nice i
love people but lady i don't like this
drew
i
show of hands everybody who thinks that
this is just unacceptable
[Music]
[Applause]
the people have spoken yes we have i
couldn't believe this story i know it's
so rude it's just you it's just you
right but i do love the woman who said
you know what
i'm so sorry i don't need this i'm out
no
she
is on the side of self-respecting and
right and i'm totally here for it yes
and can i just say and i'm announcing
this right now when i run for president
my platform is going to be that
everyone in the bridal party gets to
pick their own dress okay all right
bridesmaids you get to pick
and i appreciate your vote thank you i i
love it i want you to be president
um okay finally it's time for a pic from
drew's little yellow book um feels weird
to say my name
these are actually uh vitamins that my
dear friend alicia silverstone sent me
they're her brand
that's right
um
it's my kind organics vitamins and um i
am totally hooked i take the
multi daily it's like this yummy
chewy
raspberry uh flavor and it's got this
great density i really like it and these
are clean plant-based vitamins with no
sugar or sweeteners added there you go
and uh you've got all the greatest hits
every vitamin you could ever imagine
is she has hit me with a gummy i want to
try they're fantastic
what's this um and she has apple cider
vinegar turmeric vitamin d
but i literally
um these are delicious i literally take
her
multivitamin every day and i i will say
that i
you know i
i treat my body a little bit like an
amusement park yeah what does everyone
get a ride
i did have my fun back in the day but
i've been single for six years i
understood so um but thanks to alicia i
am like now taking my vitamins that's
great well i understand why because
these are so good they're so good so i
wanted to share what has totally
improved my quality of life with you
guys and that's it
[Music]
you